- I won't intentionally fuck you over
if you don't fuck me over.
- K. Deal
(Bright Jazz Music)
- We're gonna pull little messages out of
this little container, and
we're gonna spin the wheel.
We're gonna see who we're gonna text.
- I'm gonna say I'm most
nervous about my grandparents.
- Well I have the
numbers to all of my exes
and I'm not homies with them at all.
- (singing) We're about
to put you on blast!
- I actually am a little nervous
- Just the idea of like
giving you my phone
makes me nervous.
- There's anxiety there.
- Yeah.
- Alright, let's do it.
(Ding)
- Really get in there deep.
- Where did this game come from?
This seems like not a good idea.
- This says, "I honestly can't stand sex."
Even better.
Alright. I honestly can't
stand sex, to your moms.
- She's gonna be like,
"I didn't even think
you were dating anyone."
- (both laugh)
- You still selling drugs? Good.
- Oh, yes! Ha!
- Are you shitting me?
- Oh, you don't even have
a text history with...
- No! I know! I know.
- Oo! Out of the blue.
So, I sent "You still
sellin' drugs?" To...
- To my ex.
- To his ex.
- Do we have to play this game?
I hope that there's no response.
- Can I get a picture of your feet?
- This is good.
- Number neighbor!
- I'm gonna spice it up a little bit.
You know how I like it.
Can I get a picture of your feet?
- You know how I like it?
[Ding]
- When was the last time you were cuddled?
- Oh; that's kind of adorable.
Why are you getting adorable ones?
- 'Cuz I'm cute.
- That would be a good solid...
Oh, wow, good.
So I'm gonna text your ex.
"When was the last time you were cuddled?"
- I'm sweating right now.
- Still wanna see those pics?
- Oo.
- Smiley wink face.
Oh no; oh, thank god! (laugh)
(ding)
Still wanna see those pics, winky face.
I'm gonna do, "Still
wanna see those pics..."
Opening it up to maybe something serious.
I don't know.
- Uh oh. My ex texted me back.
She said, "Was that for me?"
- Oh, at least, okay.
- Yeah, well, of course it was.
What should I say?
- You should say, "Donald
Trump is my celebrity crush."
[Ding]
- How many times do I have to tell you?
I'm not having sex with you!
- My mom again! (laugh)
She's gonna be like
very concerned about my
online dating life after this (laugh).
- I am now texting Elana's mom,
"How many times do I have to tell you
I'm not having sex with you!"
And I'm hitting send.
- I hope you like bananas,
because I'm bringing the heat!
- God, I hope you get ex.
- She ain't gonna get a chance.
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- Yes!
- No!
- I hope you like bananas,
because I'm bringing the heat!
- How much are plungers?
This is urgent. (laugh)
- OK, ladies.
That would be a good tweet.
Ask and you shall receive.
- Just tweeted, "How much
are plungers this is urgent"
in all caps.
I've never thought you were
all that great, honestly.
- Cuts to the core.
- I mean, even if I sent that to my boss,
I think it would feel bad.
- Oh my god! Oh no!
- No!
- Sorry grams
- Grandma, I love you;
just letting you know that.
- This would be a fun
- Drinking game.
- Yeah.
- This a fun party game.
- This is a sleepover game.
- It's like an emergency contact list,
but like much more
personal and terrifying.
- We might have ruined
your family relationships
and maybe, you know,
stirred up some old flame,
but I had fun.
- (grandmother on phone) My
grandson is in deep shit.
I told them, I said, "I'm
going to call him back
and tell him, 'You are
in hot, hot mud, dude.'"
(Swish. Sign creaking)